[Music]
[Music]
welcome
welcome thank you all thank you for
coming to technology day I am IRA
Hawkman I am the chair of the Technology
Day committee this year and in first I'd
like to take you through a an honored
ritual here a technology day first I
will invite you to join me as I remove
my cell phone and turn it off
I do first I'd like to thank a few
people specifically the fantastic
committee of people that I had working
with me this year that have put together
this program for you they're very
energetic great ideas and a very fun
bunch to work with very enjoyable I'd
also like to definitely thank the
faculty for taking time to put together
these presentations and for being here
today to talk to us I'd like to also
specifically thank Lou Alexander of the
Alumni Association who basically manages
the entire process of Technology Day
he's a great guy to work with definitely
fun and totally reliable it's great I'd
also like to thank the audience all of
you both here in the auditorium and
today we are also being webcast live so
I'd like to thank the audience at home
or wherever you are with your laptop who
are enjoying this today so I'm very
excited about today's program the
subject is energy which has become a
major concern worldwide mi t--'s
response to this has been the creation
of the energy Research Council and
subsequently the MIT Energy Initiative
today's program focus will be on the
evolution of today's energy environment
as well as a discussion of how we can
improve security and effectiveness of
today's energy programs and systems the
format is a little different than last
year after we have president Hockfield
remarks we'll have three faculty members
speak each speaker has 50 minutes it was
about 40 minutes for the presentation
and up to ten minutes for the questions
since that's such a short time I please
ask you to present your questions so
that there is time for answers and
further questions
there will not be a panel QA after the
talk this year I'd also like to mention
a recent addition to the technology day
program which are the poster sessions
you may have noticed outside in Kresge
Auditorium these are award-winning
student research projects and we'd like
to also thank sally sus knowit's of the
MIT public service center for putting
together is offering outside and I would
also encourage you to enjoy a
conversation with the students behind
these product projects during the break
so with that I would like to introduce
to you
Beth Garvin the executive VP CEO of the
MIT Alumni Association she's been with
MIT for more than 20 years and was named
head of the Association in 2003
please welcome Beth Cobb
good morning it's my pleasure to welcome
you and to greet so many old friends and
meet some new ones we're delighted to
have you here this weekend for tech
reunions and for this our biggest alumni
event of intellectual nature tech night
at the Pops is probably our biggest in
terms of size overall but we really
focus on something important today I
have the privilege of leading your
association and I do that very ably
supported by a couple folks I want to
mention one is president Hockfield who
has been incredibly supportive of all of
the alumni activities has been out to
meet many of you around the world in the
two years she's been here and I just
cannot say enough how important her
presence is and her participation in all
these events it used to be that the
president of MIT would go to three
reunion events over the course of this
very busy weekend with commencement and
the ROTC hooding and all the activities
Susan likes to do three or four a night
so it really is an extraordinary
investment of time and energy for which
we're very grateful the other group of
course are the volunteers who make all
of these activities possible we have
more than a more than an event a day
around the world and if you add in the
things that are being webcast and
carried online in various ways there's
just an enormous amount of really
wonderful stuff going on and that's due
to the many volunteers who support the
Association many of whom are in this
room and you'll see from this program
today just how wonderful they are at
putting together these events and
finally I just want to acknowledge what
has to be the best Alumni Association
staff on the planet I appreciate how
many of you have come up and given me
compliments on their work they really
are extraordinarily hard-working and
we're here to make your weekend as
enjoyable as possible we always
encourage feedback though don't usually
have to encourage this audience too much
to tell us what they think but please
their evaluations we're always trying to
make things
even more interesting even more fun so
do give us your feedback and I hope I
get a chance to say hello to everybody
today enjoy the program
[Applause]
thank you very much Beth so it's my
great pleasure and honor to introduce
someone you may be familiar with the
16th president of MIT president Susan
Hockfield
good morning everyone it's not so sunny
today but you know what
it was sunny yesterday we were blessed
with a glorious day for commencement and
we are blessed I said with the fabulous
program for today thank you John for
your great introductions and for your
work pulling today's events together and
I want to just use a minute to thank
Beth and her amazing team you know she
talks about how I'd want to do three or
four events a night during Reunion
Weekend it would be absolutely
impossible without this crackerjack team
that actually does create schedules for
me that I described as a jigsaw puzzle
you know the events are knit together
like this so I know I saw many of you
last night and at your fantastic events
the mood is among you I can reflects the
mood on campus which is optimistic
uhland and very much excited about what
MIT is doing on campus and frankly what
we contribute to the world Tech Day is
always one of the highlights for me and
partly because I get to see so many of
you but also because we get to hear from
MIT faculty leaders about the work that
they're doing and how the Institute
addresses the pressing challenges of the
world today we're going to focus on what
many people consider and I'm among them
perhaps the world's greatest challenge
right now it's a challenge energy
sustainable energy how we can use it
without using up our important resources
those resources include the capacity of
the atmosphere to take up co2 it's also
an area where we believe MIT can make
unique contributions now while I'm going
to provide a little bit of an
introduction to the energy talks that
you're going to be hearing we will have
Q&A at the end and I welcome questions
on any topic now interestingly enough
the best way to think about mi t--'s
work on energy is to begin not here in
Cambridge
but in Switzerland at this year's World
Economic Forum in Davos last January at
Davos this year we had a very strong MIT
present we presents we had more than a
does
faculty members who accompanied me over
the course of several days we had 17
faculty presentations at the World
Economic Forum
there were several MIT events in Zurich
and at Davos including a dinner that we
hosted on disruptive energy technologies
our work there was enormous ly greeted
we agreed with enormous enthusiasm and
rather than brag about it myself I
thought I'd just read from you from what
the Time Magazine's Davos correspondent
wrote at a certain point during this
year's World Economic Forum annual
meeting in Davos the gusts of self
regard became a little too much to bear
I found myself wondering whether any of
this high-minded talk was worth a dime
fortunately that's when something came
along to remind me of what Davos is good
for my breakthrough session turned out
to be a guided tour of the future mi
t--'s dinner session on destructive
energy technologies now at the dinner we
had three of our faculty speak angie
Belcher talked about the viruses that
she's persuaded to make batteries
vladimir Bulova CH talked about solar
photovoltaics and quantum dots
Greg Stephanopoulos talked about a very
large and fascinating biofuels project
and Tom Friedman who you know from his
work the New York Times was our
introducer and moderated the discussion
back to Time magazine
no wonder MIT president Susan Hockfield
seeing those sorts of discoveries taking
place in nooks and crannies all around
her Cambridge campus decided to gather
scientists into an Energy Research
Council and declare war on the energy
crisis accelerating the switch to clean
efficient fuels solving this crisis
Hockfield told us as candles flickered
in the little stone grotto in Davos will
take not one solution but a portfolio of
solutions it's a sprint and a marathon
learning what her scientists are up to
made me feel better about our chances in
this race and that's what Davos is good
for a helping of authentic reality-based
hope right when you need it the most and
that is where I begin
what MIT is good for a dose of authentic
reality based hope that we can help
address in a real way the most serious
of the world's great challenges now I'm
sure I don't need to rehearse for this
audience what actually frames our global
energy challenge there is accelerating
demand China alone is increasing its
energy use by 10 percent a year the
world over is on track to double our
energy use by 2050 the security of our
sources of energy our historical sources
of energy are shall we say not so stable
increasingly those energy sources the
energy they've set itself oil is in the
hands of companies that are controlled
by States those states are shall we say
can't be relied upon to be the most
friendly to our country and then the
environmental implications of our
current technology people may argue
about the cause of about whether the
increased co2 in the atmosphere is the
cause of global warming
I personally believe what the
preponderance of scientists say about
this but if you look at the
concentration of co2 in the atmosphere
that was about 280 parts per million in
1900's it is 380 parts per million today
it is rising at a rate that is
absolutely unsustainable whether that is
the cause of global warming or no we are
using up a limited resource and that
limited resource is the capacity of our
atmosphere to hold co2 in a way that is
sustainable as consistent with life as
we know it on this planet mit is
response to this energy challenge is the
MIT Energy Initiative the emanation
grow-out grew out of interest I heard
from faculty students staff and alumni
as I was learning about the MIT
community when I asked our community
what are mi t--'s responsibilities and
opportunities over the next decade or
two there was an overwhelming call for
MIT to do more to help solve this global
crisis the energy resource Research
Council released its report after a year
study just about a year ago it was
released concurrent with an institute
why
energy forum that was about Heldman
about the busiest week of the year we
held it in Kresge Kresge was packed this
past fall we announced the formal begin
of the MIT Energy Initiative the
initiative is headed by Ernie Moniz with
a Deputy Director Bob Armstrong one of
the most exciting things about MIT
Energy Initiative is not the huge number
of people who have begun to participate
but the fact that people are
participating in this from all five of
our schools the Energy Initiative has
drawn out three main themes the first is
new technologies for a cleaner future
and there were focusing on solar on
biofuels and on energy storage the
second theme is improving today's energy
systems for changes in the near-term and
there were focusing on nuclear clean
carbon and carbon dioxide capture and
sequestration the third theme is
addressing the challenges posed by the
emerging economies and there we feel we
can be particularly helpful in the areas
of transportation and construction and
our three faculty speakers today will
lead you through a few let's just say
three of the very many important strands
that comprise the Energy Initiative as I
said an important aspect of the Energy
Initiative is that it reaches across all
of the schools every theme every
research direction requires
collaboration from many different
departments in many different schools
each research area that I hear described
by the Energy Initiative participants is
not an area that could be addressed by
one faculty member or one department or
one school each requires participation
across MIT and each also requires not
simply new technology or new science
each requires technology and policy
working together the Energy Initiative
is not just about research importantly
it's also about education there is
enormous student enthusiasm and interest
and one of the first active
of the energy initiative was to put
together a task force on education we
have a marvelous committee that's
addressing that and we now have a
website that presents to our students
the range of energy related courses
available on campus and the student
interest as I said has just been
overwhelming it's also important for MIT
to what we say walk the talk so one of
the initiatives first task forces is a
task force on campus sustainability to
use our campus as a living laboratory so
we can do what we're talking about and
what we're urging the rest of the world
to do the most important message
emerging out of our work is that we have
to develop a portfolio of solutions
there is not a single silver bullet we
can't focus on one solution to address
it we have to at the same time pursue
many different avenues you know when I
first heard about the energy challenge I
thought about it as a challenge and you
know it's all seriousness about wearing
extra sweaters and turning down the
thermostat and it seemed like boy it was
just gonna you know was kind of a sorry
thing after talking to our faculty being
in my own energy course from our faculty
and students over the last two years I
now see this as a fantastic opportunity
an opportunity not just for a campus but
an opportunity for the nation it's an
opportunity to inspire the young people
of the nation around a bright future
that they can help invent I see this as
the possibility of having the same kind
of catalytic and an inspirational effect
that the Apollo program had on my
generation the other great opportunity
is the possibility that energy new
energy technologies will fuel the next
cycle of the innovation economy that has
made this nation so strong we see that
around here or energy startups and
actually large energy companies are
moving into the MIT is backyard it
resembles in many ways the beginning of
the life science revolution and the
marvelous life science companies that
have come out of places like MIT around
the world now of course energy is not
the only way in which mi t--'s faculty
students and staff are working together
to address the world's most critical
needs and we could have picked any one
of a number of topics to present to you
today but
I would say overall there is a huge
sense of operative optimism and
opportunity on campus about what MIT is
good for a dose of authentic reality
based hope that we can contribute to
solving the world's great challenges in
this role MIT has been for decades and
decades a real beacon for the world now
thanks to an extraordinarily generous
alumnus who was inspired by the idea of
taking the basket off this beacon off
the lamp tonight
we're going to celebrate a symbolic way
of taking the basket off the lamp and we
will reignite one of mi t--'s most
powerful symbols after sunset tonight
which occurs late because we are near
the longest day of the year for the
first time in more than three decades we
will fully relight the Great Dome the
relighting is possible because of
advances in energy-saving lighting
technologies the power consumption of
our new lighting techniques is going to
consume energy that's equal to two hair
dryers or I've been told the amount of
energy that's currently is consumed by
lighting in my office we've got to get
to work on the lighting in my office so
the lighting itself is very low energy
consuming but in addition to that again
because of the generosity of this
alumnus who has insisted on remaining
anonymous we are also going to be
installing 40 kilowatt photovoltaic cell
actually which greatly exceeds the call
on energy by the by the dome lighting
but we see this dome lighting as a way
to walk the talk times two the first is
demonstrating energy efficient lighting
we don't have to give up a lot of them
wonderful things we enjoy we just have
to do things in a more energy efficient
way and the second really important part
of mi t--'s contributions is inspiring
the nation of the world about the
wonderful promise of a brighter future
for all through science and technology
let me just close by echoing some
things that Beth said when she
introduced the session this morning
I cannot overestimate the importance of
alumni engagement of course if you
should go without saying that your
generous financial support is essential
for us to be able to do the kind of
extraordinary frontier advancing work
that we do and to bring the most able
and ambitious students in the world to
this campus and I'm gonna thank you a
little bit more in that domain at lunch
but for now I really want to thank you
for the very many other roles you play
as members of the MIT community one
especially critical role is as
ambassadors from MIT to the world and I
very much hope that all of you will
continue to spread the good news of mi
t--'s contributions to solving the
world's great challenges and how we
educate young people from MIT to be the
people who engineer who develop the
science who understand the policy of
bringing those solutions to bear on
these great challenges thank you very
much for joining us for this reunion
weekend let me stop there and take a few
seconds a few questions before we move
on to our faculty presentations thank
you
[Applause]
any questions from the floor before we
yes there are mics oh you're up there
okay so you'll have to speak very loudly
please
[Music]
yeah but it's obvious that MIT can make
major contributions in science and
technology but are we also working on
the policy the economic piece of the
puzzle and indeed we are the energy
Council which is the five faculty who
are primary advisors to Ernie Moniz and
Bob Bob Armstrong come from each of the
five schools and we have a number of
faculty in humanities Arts and Social
Sciences and MIT Sloan who are actually
very interested in these policy economic
issues and I think you'll be hearing a
little bit about some of that today I'm
looking at nicely and she's not nodding
or we're gonna hear a little bit about
some of their policy work today
and we actually feel on that for a
couple of reasons that MIT can knit the
Science and Technology together with the
policy in almost unique ways partly
because we have people on campus who are
working on both sides of that equation
but also because MIT has an almost
unique practice faculty working across
what in other places our departmental
and school boundaries as I think about
at least the parts of my tasties history
then I know what I always think about is
the study that led to the book made in
America that was brought forth during
the Japanese threat on the American
economy made in America was done by a
group called the Industrial Performance
Center which is a group of economists
people from MIT Sloan engineers and
scientists that group continues to
produce a bunch of a number of books and
actually their most recent book out of
that group the the main author is
Suzanne Berger it's a book called how we
compete and it's exactly just exactly
what you asked it's a study of economics
and business practices in the context of
global globally successful businesses so
indeed the short answer I should have
said is yes we are going to be we are
doing both the economics and the
technology around the energy challenges
other questions you'll have to actually
speak up because it's hard for me to see
if there's anyone at a microphone
if not we will proceed with the oh thank
you welcome you invade our government
leaders that we need programs like
Apollo in this area well I think we all
can lend our voice to that call like MIT
presidents before me I spend a day every
four to six weeks in Washington working
to persuade them actually on these
issues I spend time in Congress at the
White House at with the heads of the
various agencies actually making this
call and I think we need to you know as
a nation articulate our interest in a
very loud way on our belief that the
Energy Challenge could represent the
kind of issue to which the nation as a
whole could direct its interest its
enthusiasm its ambitions so that's I'd
say you are very important as MIT
ambassadors to the world if you all lend
your voice to this possibility I'm it
will amplify the things that I can do in
person you know 120,000 fold I think is
a number of our alumni right now
anything else well again thank you very
much for joining us for tech day thanks
for coming back to campus I hope you'll
like what you see and as Beth said this
is not a shy group we look forward to
hearing from you about your reflections
on this weekend on campus welcome to MIT
[Applause]
Thank You president Hockfield for those
very interesting information
particularly hearing about the exciting
research and implementation going on at
MIT transporting us to Switzerland and
also for setting us on edge for the
words of our next speaker there are
detailed biographies of the speakers in
your program books but I would like to
highlight some facets of our next
speaker professor nicely to Crete in
addition to being a professor in mi
t--'s political science department
she is also associate director of the
technology and development program and
head of the Middle East program at MIT
professor Chuck Ruiz primary research
focus is in international relations an
international political economy with a
special focus on conflict connectivity
and the global environment this puts her
in a particularly advantageous
perspective to comment on the broader
context of the energy challenges we now
face political economic and strategic as
well as the types of coordination that
the major nations of the world will need
to develop to ensure our energy future
I'd also like to mention that there are
microphones located in the aisles if you
have questions please feel free to line
up at the microphones so please join me
in welcoming professor Nazli kukri
[Applause]
Thank You IRA for this very gracious
introduction I'm going to ask you to
work with me as we place energy in a
global context in part and parts of what
I will say will not seem obvious as to
what the energy connections are and this
is where your homework comes in helping
me out on this
so the am I doing this right
this is not my machine I have no clue
how this thing works okay we'll try
again ah it's this way right sorry yeah
this is the social sciences I'm already
talking I'm going to be talking about
three issues and each one of them is
really quite important the first is to
take stock of the legacy of the 20th
century what is it that we're carrying
with us today the second is to look at
the global system as a whole and in what
I will refer to as some odd views of the
system and and finally some political
realities for energy in in the 21st
century so we'll take those one at a
time on the legacies I have chosen to
focus on four core ones and then look at
some of the surprises the good news the
bad news and the unexpected from which I
will ask how I will propose the balance
sheet what do we have what we get out of
this what are the net effects so aren't
the legacies the ones that I've chosen
are self-evident but there are surprises
in each one of them the first is
population dynamics and were all
familiar where the rapid population
growth almost in one word then the issue
of some issues related to technology and
implications for energy use some energy
basics in the really most basic sense is
seen from a political scientists and
then a reminder the fourth legacy is a
reminder of the new global agenda the
new global political agenda the world
out there that is changing perhaps far
more rapidly than then we are able to
understand or accommodate it so one one
legacy at a time on population dynamics
we all know that there are more people
on this planet we also know that there's
some important demographic shifts
we're not exactly sure what the shifts
are or how important they are but we
know they're out there and then finally
the biggest legacy we have of the 20th
century is the matter of crossing
borders just about everybody on this
planet is on the move for one reason or
another and every move is related to
some increment of energy use the
statistics that we have about mobility
of people and the venues and the
duration and location and the sources
and the consequences are not quite
synchronized with the needs that we need
the knowledge that we need with respect
to the associated energy uses so first
the familiar which is more people on
this planet and I don't need to say
anything more about it the the insert
here is perhaps a little less familiar
and this is believe it or not there has
been a slight improvement in the human
condition since over the past century or
so in the sense that the share of the
poor has declined now you may consider
that good news but place in the context
of the demands and the needs of the poor
population that's not as good news as we
would want and then let's factor in the
energy requirements almost by necessity
as we all become wealthier richer better
off and so forth and here's a minor
footnote the individual Joe Smith let's
say John Doe living in China is embedded
in a energy infrastructure that is quite
different so his his own individualized
per-capita consumption would is very
different than if Joe Smith or John Doe
whoever it is moves to Los Angeles and
the same individual nothing is strange
about him or her simply the
infrastructure within which he works has
changed and there the the energy numbers
look look quite
as a simple reminder as to the mobility
of people now this is very misleading
because I should give you the other side
of it which I'm not going to give you
and that is the the percentage of
migrants to the total population which
is which is not not in this case the
only thing I want to draw your attention
to is that movement across borders
generating a stock measured at one point
in time is very very large and the word
migrant here refers to voluntary
movement people who willingly desire to
cross borders most people only put it
differently there's a large fraction of
crossing borders that is not not not
voluntary that to carries with it some
some energy-related coefficients leaving
aside the coefficients related to
justice quality of life etc so what I've
covered so far are the related to you
know basic facts let's talk about some
some surprises and this is where I ask
you to consider the the implications the
first surprise has to do with at the
unexpected declines in fertility we had
never thought fifty years ago six years
ago thirty years ago
over thirty years ago and I joined the
MIT faculty that would consider this an
issue decline second surprise and I'll
get to do that in more that in a minute
the second surprise is is is the
dependency ratio in population and then
finally the the aging Society the aging
society is a car let it connect it is
connected to tightly coupled tightly
with the industrializing Society so the
question to you is the quiz for this
morning is do you see any energy related
impacts either on the demand side or on
the distribution side or the
infrastructure requirements side or is
this just a blip
in our statistics and hey life is
complicated so let's let's look at the
fertility declines what you see here is
a fairly good representation of what we
now understand to be a basic fact and
this is in industrialized countries the
populations are not reproducing
themselves now we consider that a
problem we consider that one could
consider that a problem in the old days
the only problem of familiar with is
rapid population growth too many people
are having too many children and I not
passing judgment here I'm simply saying
that this is a surprise because we had
not expected it we had not looked for it
we had not anticipated it and this is
this comes from the economists and and I
just love this one for the following
reasons there were plenty of clues
before the popular press picked up the
fact that the Russians were disappearing
and here it has to do mainly with a
fertility side that the death rate and
the life expectancy of the Russian then
the Soviet population was going down
having to deal with health-related
issues having to do with inhaling too
many stuff that's not good for you
etc and we saw that long before we're
able to connect energy climate change
potentials pollution and health
pieces that we now take for granted as
going as going together this is not very
good news for the Russians at least I
don't think it's it's good news for them
and the standard policy that countries
have when they face well faced with news
that they don't consider good is to try
to do something and we know based on the
history of the advanced industrial
countries that it is any policy to try
to increase the fertility rate in
advanced industrial country is doomed to
failure has failed to no end a case in
point here would be would be France
this is probably more than you really
want to know but it's not connecting
much more closely to the energy issue
and I just want to draw your attention
to the to this to this black to the
solid black line which is a growth
expand the arising dependency ratio
which is the ratio of the non-working
population to the working population and
we really don't want to have this
dependency ratio go up because it means
that the working population has to
support a larger fraction of the total
population so on the under the quiz
sheet for this morning is is this trend
that we now think is fairly robust is it
neutral with respect to energy effects
on any dimension of the energy issue now
we move on to the technology parts and
in in this audience I will not presume
to say anything technical on on the
technology aspect but I will so I will
focus specifically on three issues that
are fundamentally important legacies of
the 20th century and are going to face
shape how we deal with with the 21st
century on energy issues and out just
about everything else under the Sun the
first is globalization and the
persistence of this thing that we call a
globalization we did a rough census of
what globalization means and I won't
bore you with the varieties of
definitions that that we came up with in
the literature and in the popular press
but the fact is everything is crossing
borders with its people ideas things and
so forth the second issue is
globalization and no I did not make this
word up this comes from the United
Nations coining of this concept to
reflect the conjunction of globalization
processes but the localization effect
of globalization so the linkages between
globalization and and localization the
the the interesting thing here is that
we now know that there are many local
effects that have been generated by the
globalization process so it's not a
decoupling it's a recovering in a
different way
what we don't yet know is how we can
connect this fact I would say to our
energy policies our energy strategies
and of course to the application of
innovation in this area so consider this
the next item on on the quiz the the
third energy issue that is very very
important
goes without saying is the global race
for knowledge it's not the global arms
race of the olden days but it is a race
nonetheless and what I was what I will
draw your attention to it in just a
minute is the impact of this race on one
particular domain and that is the shifts
what has this done to shift the way in
which we organize and think about our
our social activities and about where
value added is or added value is sources
of added value there are multiple
indicators of globalization I don't I
don't need to persuade you that there is
something going on out there in the
world
the simplest trend I could get around
which there would be no controversy more
or less is is well trade so take that as
a an indicator most interesting however
is the impact of knowledge knowledge
intensity the the impact of this the
impact of shifting the structure of
economies and the structure of societies
and it's and we're moving in that
direction and as we go down that path
what implications are there for for
energy
would like to think that it's got to be
only good news but I'm an optimist so
what we've already started to see as a
legacy from the 20th century is a
gradual shift from the strict thinking
about supply chain requirements as been
anchors of meeting supply chain
requirements as being anchors to to the
economy and to the social order to
thinking about the knowledge chain and
what we're doing here at MIT is
beginning to formalize and clarify what
would be meant by the knowledge chain
and at which point society is gained by
reducing disconnects among various links
to that to that chain we've also seen
shifts from material output that wish to
have expanded material output to the
wish to have better ways of meeting
social social needs we're seeing shifts
from knowledge access reducing barriers
to access to enhancing facilitating
venues for knowledge generation and
knowledge creation so we're beginning to
think of knowledge not as the residual
in the proverbial textbook case of the
production function in the in the old
days but as really endogenous entire
process and then the final shift that is
the most fabulous of all at this point
in time and it was alluded to earlier by
a president Hockfield is the the
interest that we have in contributing to
the diffusion and the distribution of of
of knowledge now this sounds a very much
like motherhood and an apple pie and I
certainly don't mean to sound that way
what I do want to say is that if we can
understand and unbundle
the knowledge chain and if we can locate
the the value of doing this with respect
to our energy dilemmas challenges
problems we might be one step ahead
in framing our response policies
surprises what are the surprises from a
socio-economic and political point of
view and to me the most obvious surprise
of all looking back at the 20th century
and if we were if we were anticipating
technological changes it would have been
very difficult then at the beginning of
the 20th century to have correctly
anticipating the forging of a virtual
space cyberspace the internet etc to the
architects of this space the focus has
been on the internet and the wires and
whatever else goes into into this thing
but for the social scientists and for
the users is the creation forging of new
spaces new irate arenas of interactions
and new voicing and new opportunities
and again connect new voicing and new
opportunities to who is doing the
voicing and who is doing the
opportunities and what difference it
might make the last piece of the the
last mile if you wish is the wire and
less connections at as part of this
bundle of surprises I'll get to that in
just a moment to the second surprise is
that environment does in fact matter
it's not something that we would have
anticipated early in the 20th century
and then the third surprise is the dark
side that states are at risk from
factors that we did not expect them to
be at risk from so what now or what next
opportunities this is the an example of
internet generated revenues I don't have
the sources here for which I apologize
but it comes from an economist report
and
the amount and the access isn't the bees
of course so more with more comes more
regulatory stuff as a particular
scientist I take it for granted that any
new activity creates a new bureaucracy
of some sort now that is not really good
news it may be necessary but it's not
really good news because we know that
major major major disconnects in just
basic communication among bureaucracies
and among agencies who have the same
mission statement so we're creating
we're creating ahead of ourselves that
we may not necessarily want to another
part of the other technological surprise
and I put it on the side of technology
here as opposed to on the side of the
ledger of the social scientists who
could have tried it a little harder to
anticipate some of those differences
there are two two pieces of the
surprises that are important in terms of
the environmental effects of of our
industrialization trajectory one is the
differential impacts across and within
countries which you know but second is
that there are going to be already but
there will continue to be more burdens
on the poor but everywhere in all
societies this society as well does
energy policy factored into this at all
by now you may think that the connection
between energy and the issues that I'm
raising is is far too long the chain
there is too long but let me assure that
it really is not if you if you consider
it carefully because we're also seeing
anticipating the prospects of more
social cleavages as potential effects of
climate change arise the next item on on
this checklist is the erosion of the
power of governance and the power
of institutions if they get overloaded
by the effects of the transformations in
the natural environment without spending
too much too much time on this the the
other side of the lusts of law and order
is the growth in individual
entrepreneurship self-help if you wish
and remember societies are organized to
prevent excessive self self-help so what
we worry about here is that we have not
thought out about enough thought enough
about the potential consequences on the
social order of this particular surprise
and now we understand that this is
terrifically important and where are at
least in the BRIC science department
spending serious time looking at that
that issue the there is something some
attempt to measure the the International
impacts of potential climate change you
notice a highlight potential just in
case there are controversies on on this
issue and the climate change index is
now considered as plausibly accurate
with respect to countries at risk at
risk with respect to health hazards
physical and physical conditions as well
as immediate environmental impact of
environmental dislocation this is not
really very good news but I think that
as we think about the energy climate or
energy environment linkages we're going
to have to recognize that there are
significant high probability outcomes
that we're going to have to deal with
somewhat seriously the and I have
identified sharing with you two of those
of those here the first bullet is
respected 10 countries that are high
in terms of overall risk and you have
the list of the countries here but these
are countries that so far account for a
very small amount of greenhouse gas
emissions some of these countries will
be going under reconstruction programs
and so the challenge is is it possible
to have no how can we best engage in
reconstruction without putting in place
the energy economy interactions that
were destroyed to begin with and
president Hockfield referred to
efficiencies on the MIT campus and
efficiencies be imposed upon transferred
portable to a large scale reconstructing
a reconstruction efforts we hope so
but the record so far in terms of the
reconstruction of destroyed economies in
the last over the last decade or so
shows us that we are very good at
reconstructing what we've already
destroyed we're not good at putting in
place the new generations of
technologies that are already available
to us okay this is a simple reminder of
the distribution of who's going to be in
pain on this one and without any any
statement about the nature of the pain
and now I get to the darker side the the
countries at at risk at risk of conflict
or at risk on being the recipient of
unhappiness that is generated elsewhere
associated with climate related related
issues there is a concentration as you
can see in in the African continent
there are also a bunch of other
concentrations the interesting thing
about this is that this assessment comes
out of the community that focuses on
climate related impacts and the fact
that they're concerned with
flecked at exactly the time in which the
political conflict community in
political sciences began to think about
the environmental event is an example of
the type of coupling that we've started
to do and we're getting to be more much
more involved with and let me let me
stress the obvious by way of indicating
how important this is the coupling part
and that is the social sciences as all
of the sciences but I'll speak only with
the social sciences were framed and
developed over time by very carefully
carving out partitioning human activity
out of the natural environment and
looking at this piece and then very
carefully cutting up pieces of human
activity so you have the politics for
the political scientist economics for
the economists and so forth with the
realize a knowing that the world is not
that way but understanding that this is
how we will generate knowledge faster
now we realize that the strategy that
has been very successful throughout the
20th century and before is a major
liability today so now what we're trying
to do is put Humpty Dumpty together
again but in a way that does not
undermine the growth and the strength of
the individual disciplines and the
individual fields needless to say this
is easier said than done but they are
more important than the most serious
part of this is that the need to
reconnect is one that comes from within
the fields so there's a very powerful
realization that we have to reshape our
system boundaries and our field
boundaries now the the issue of energy
basics you know the third set of of
legacies fossil fuels the usual I don't
need to review that with you
second legacy has to do with the
continued politicization of energy
energy as you know is an intensely
political issues across across the globe
maybe with the exception of legislation
butchers there's a search for
alternatives the usual maybe more than
usual but then we have the mess in the
Middle East which is clearly more than
than the usual when you put all these
things together we have some immediate
short-term dilemmas we won't call them
crises and professor Deutsch may address
those in in a few minutes but what I'd
like to do is share with you the view
that the usual is a little bit more
messy than it has been in the past this
is a simple reminder of the flow of
exports of oil and global oil I just
pick this one up because the message is
very very clear and you see the salience
and the centrality of of the Middle East
and followed by a vision from the Boston
Globe in 1986 this this actually is very
accurate 86 is decades ago no more I
mean you're familiar with this but there
is unfortunately one more angle on that
which is this way the message here may
not be what you think it is it has to do
with in addition to this mess we have a
mess where there are many many players
not all of which are controlled by
States and not all of which define
winning and losing the same way this is
the complexity of the Middle East the
good news is that this particular
cartoon is not about a major
oil-producing or natural gas pretty
in region it is differences of
perspective over a non-oil producing
area so if we take this cartoon and put
it on the future of Saudi Arabia or the
future of Iran or the future of you name
your favorite oil producer we have a
slightly complicated situation that's
going to create imperatives for us right
right right now this is one of the most
powerful legacies of of the 20th century
the just to show you that I'm able to be
even-handed on this this comes from Time
magazine you may not be able to see it
so I'll tell you why this is interesting
it is a set of instances in which the
good guys by the good guys I mean
countries like Norway begin to do some
rather unpleasant things over energy
related over resource related matters
and energy related matters and the case
in which the clashes this is a case of
Japan between Japanese fishermen and the
Russian Navy and then we have the
Chinese and that's right the Chinese
oops sorry I shouldn't touch this stuff
help
[Music]
against somebody sorry
I'm not going to be embarrassed so don't
try okay eventually you can get a hard
copy of this I apologize because it's
not very clear but but the the the
Russians try to pressure the Georgians
by boycotting their wine and their
mineral water over some dispute and that
had some connections to the pricing of
imports and exports of commodities now
the surprise in the energy from my
social science point of view first we
hadn't expected the breakdown of the
Soviet Union it came too quick too fast
and too thorough but what it did do is
shift control over known energy
resources the new state owners have new
priorities and most of the time we're
not exactly sure what their priorities
are so the uncertainties for us go up
and I don't talk about security issues
this is just legacies and the bottom
line of this on the political economy of
energy that's been handed to us from the
20th century is uncertainties about who
controls what in the shorter shorter
time than horizon now to the fourth to
the fourth and last part of the legacy
of the 20th century I've picked up what
I believed to be the ones that will
remain powerful throughout the the 21st
century the salience of environment is
very very very unlikely that this is an
issue that will will go away unless we
become unbelievably creative more than
we can
imagine the evidence that we have so far
and regretfully I don't have the slide
for you is the enormous growth of
international environmental treaties
multilateral treaties this is not
treaties that contain an environmental
component clause in it but focusing
specifically on environment and the most
interesting thing about that is that the
trend of global environmental treaty
making is looks exactly the same as the
trend of u.s. participation
environmental treaty making so all
things considered what we've gotten up
from the 20th century is a very high
participation rate by the by the United
States the second major issue on the
global agenda that is clearly new is the
issue of sustainability and sustainable
development and now when you drill into
the issue we come up against
sustainability sustainable energy and
strategies for the sustainable
sustainable nests of energy issues
that's of course as part of the research
agenda here the next item that is part
of the global agenda and by global
agenda I mean the global political
agenda and its potential connection its
connections to our own research agenda
is getting a better handle on the not so
much the sources of potentials for
climate change this is this is fairly
well understood what is not understood
is the nature of the consequences once
you get beyond the generalities or the
general statements particularly those
consequences for which it is possible to
intervene today you're effectively piece
of an important research agenda the
fourth item on the new global agenda for
politics in the world and for the
Academy is revisiting the fundamentals
the fundamentals in economic performance
and economic growth in the past is
always been
efficiency efficiency is really
important now we factor in a looking for
the possibility of coupling efficiency
and equity
can it be done we are assuming that it
can be done
so the pursuit of efficiency in economic
activity in policy but constraining that
in some fashion with a serious attention
to to efficiency after I'm sorry to
equity matters of equity and this then
leads us to to the final part of the
final item on the new global agenda that
that I would like to share with you and
that is there is a trend out there in
the political world in the UN world
seeking to define global public goods in
Academy were trying to articulate how
one can actually think about funding
money articulating funding and
implementing any notion of global public
public goods this is more than
international this is more than
transnational this is addressing the
nature and the composition of the
responsibility that civil society and
the global level has to itself so the
dangers on the environment side we've
gone through this before but I do want
to mention the very draw your attention
to the very last item on that and that
it matters related to infrastructure it
goes without saying that most of us
believe that if there is serious
potential of climate change if there is
sea-level rise etc etc the odds are very
very high that our physical
infrastructures are going to be affected
very very deeply seriously so what do we
do balance sheet now on the legacies of
the 20th century the good news and the
bad news the good news who that we are
going to be calling the three es cup
with some bad news that we're going to
call the missing piece the three E's is
we now understand we understand some but
we understand the need for better
understanding the interconnections
between energy environment and economy
that's a message that we all have and
it's reflected in our course offerings
as well that's the good news
now the missing piece or the bad news is
that we are ignoring some important
political realities because politics is
uncomfortable business and we really
don't like to deal with this unless we
have to for professional reasons and
that is the realities of participation
remember the internet and the virtual
spaces more people more demands more
noises etc power and power differentials
who's going to be at the table once we
think about the new energy management
regimes the Kyoto Protocol is up for for
reconsideration I guess in in six years
or so well who's going to be sitting at
that table be other than countries and
then finally the issue of politics we
talk about energy policy we do research
on energy policy we're beginning to
think about the politics associated with
getting the legislature to understand
that these are important issues or
getting the EU or getting the German
Chancellor who has been very successful
in the last few days to convince her
colleagues that energy environment is an
important global issue from a political
scientists point of view the missing
piece constitute very bad news and so we
have a responsibility to try to factor
in politics back into the energy economy
environment mix now let me show you let
me turn now to the second item for for
today and there's a light here that's
going to start blinking when I should
stop so whenever it starts blinking I
will stop the I'd like to give you some
some sense of the global system today
based on the principle on what you see
it depends on how you look at it please
take that seriously even though this
sounds like a trite observation because
I will show you some multiple realities
the size of those realities on a global
basis and you can think of this as
footprints or as burdens or whatever but
this is the world out there we'll start
with the relative view of the people the
power and the pain this is the total
world population that this is a familiar
world map kind of adjusted a little bit
to the the relative demographic
statistics per per country and this is
the same world map adjusted a little bit
to the the same people but warring from
1945 to two years ago people at war so
to speak or populations at war and this
is the same global map inflated by
percentage military spending for the
year 2002 now the only purpose of all is
I hope whole bunch that we'll share with
you is that these are conventional
indicators and hey this is the way life
is but then we have some even maybe
conventional but seriously unpleasant
situations that if we can actually
locate that those landmines and if we
can seriously think about reconstructing
those areas in which the landmines were
there have been put in place what's the
energy strategy for doing this do though
the past has shown us that we usually
build what we already know how to build
which is built in the inefficiencies
what happens next this is a who died
violently and this is who died through
self death
now the self suicide is that is a word
in the social sciences we think that
suicide is a reliable indicator of
unhappiness now the theory this is and
the individual level okay but what
happens if we try to talk about
aggregate unhappiness and I'm not trying
to draw too much into this this
distortion this is this is telling us
that if we violate the ecological
fallacy which is you can't generalize
from the individual to the state then we
have sources of real unhappiness in the
globe that we haven't we haven't
seriously paid attention to the next two
slides are the missing pieces of the
migration that I showed you long long
time ago and this is people leaving
where are they leaving from and they're
not leaving voluntarily now remember
when people cross borders they come with
their claims and their demands on
infrastructure including energy so this
is where they have left from not
voluntarily because of conflict and
violence and again refugees are not part
of the migration statistics is a
different category and this is where
they go to the interesting thing about
this other than the most obvious is the
mutually the mutual concentration in an
area which is Europe and and Africa and
the rest of the globe where we know
we're going to have under normal
circumstances not refugee related
massive investments in infrastructure
now the good news views of the world in
terms of human creativity using patterns
as an example and internet usage
indicating from my point of view the
ability for individuals to participate
or to express themselves this is Patti
granted in 2002
is there anything odd about this map
does anything strike you as not the way
we would wish it to be
the there was a question earlier to to
president Hockfield about the extent to
which we consider economic and political
economic issues in when we think about
energy and energy futures we do consider
them very much before seeing this
particular map I had not expected the
the dual balloon a few wish I had
expected the concentration to be much
more in the on the western side and this
is Internet users in 2002 for me the
Internet users represent voicing of
individuals it's the first time in human
history that an individual unit a
statistic as opposed to an aggregate is
able to articulate anything on any in
any communication venue in them on a
global scale so that's the division the
the other side of the world that we live
another view other views of the world
that that we live in a couple more
things before we move on to the
political realities think of these are
just descriptors the past wealth the
carbon emissions and the future wealth
this is the wealth of the globe at the
beginning of the last century this is
the wealth the carbon emissions and you
see that's not too difficult and this is
the wealth of the globe in 2015
projected there's a big green trunk in
there that was not anticipated before
now let's turn to the real thing which
is the political realities the politics
of energy for the 21st century
and only thing I will do is highlight
structural features
the parameters of the game rather than
policy features what should we tweak
here and there again this is what we now
have to live with we have more global
volatility it goes without saying we
have more sovereign states we have more
intergovernmental agencies we have more
multinational corporations that I
suppose is the good news but we also
have more nongovernmental organizations
that the combination of all these mores
creates a very interesting political
algorithm just a quick a quick view of
each one of those the more nation states
more civil wars and more terrorist rebel
groups in the very recent years we call
this volatility this is the creation of
new States now think about new States as
every one of those entities has a vote
positive negative or neutral and is
sitting at the table and is actually
sitting at all environment and all
energy related negotiation tables the
larger the number of in the individual
decision entities States the more
complicated things things become but
this is the world we live in the UN
membership more the establishment of
leading intergovernmental organization
which is bureaucracies at the global
level more and then we have more
multinationals and here the the figures
speak for themselves let me draw your
attention to the very last bullet and
that is 14 of the largest of the 50 of
the world's largest of 50th largest
economies are not countries they're
corporations so the economic size is
massive the political vote can never be
direct of course because corporations
don't sit around the table as individual
voters they sit around the table as part
of the lobbies or the supporters of
individual states
and the difficulty there of course is
that the global corporations have global
interests that don't always map to those
of the individual states and here is the
really really newcomer of in
instructional conditions structural
features of the world and that is the
growth in non-government nongovernmental
organizations otherwise known as NGOs
other than oh wise known as those of the
interest groups that are organized to do
good things in the world to do better in
the world etc two points are relevant
here one is they have actually been able
to secure a seat at the table at the
political table in international
agencies and international forums not
voting but they're there and they make
their views known second important thing
that's really important is that these
are entities without accountability
there is no mechanism that has yet been
invented to make these entities
accountable to to anyone really except
themselves if they have an
accountability mechanism so we consider
that important and interesting because
it's an example of incomplete
institutional design it's very unlikely
that this situation will remain as as it
is but because the voices are so strong
and they're very very strong and very
organized on both sides of the energy
issues whatever the size might be that
these are very well worth very well
worth watching so what does all this
mean and what does all this mean if we
think about global energy strategies and
global energy situations for the
remainder of a century in the context of
the priorities of the nation and the
priorities from a scientific point of
view what it means it's really quite
simple
it started to blink so I have to speed
it up here there are more stakes and
more stake holders please notice I
didn't use the word stock and stock
holders in
trysts more constraints on decision more
possibilities for spoilers and then of
course more limits on the use of force
some things that you really can't use
the traditional instruments of violence
that have been has been so effective in
the past so the bottom line is that we
are looking for we need of there's more
need of the politics of of consensus
politics by definition is about
competing competition and about conflict
now we're trying to figure out how to
push the envelope on the collaboration
and on the proverbial win win win win
situations that is part of actually
thinking about new new strategies for
negotiation
assuming we have developed the national
consensus on what we need to do now it's
not clear to me that we have a national
consensus yet but let's assume we'll
have one soon we then have to move that
consensus and try to influence the
global arena if it's the politics of
consensus that means let's talk and
there are some barriers to being able to
speak clearly for this reason and that
is that on the one hand we're moving to
a world where individuals and peoples
begin to matter that peoples are not
always willing to be funneled through
their national governments every one of
the governments of course speaks English
so this doesn't is not relevant to them
but on the other hand we've got to
figure out how to reduce the gap in in
communication in the in the in the
disconnects in our respective
communications of which language is is
one of the more pervasive barriers so
conclusion I have two conclusions so
conclusion number one is restating the
obvious let the I think it okay okay
okay
be very fast
a second bullet we have to pay an
inheritance tax we've got this legacy
let's pay the tax and not let's pay
we're going to have to and we can
minimize the pain if we this is my last
slide so allow me to take it slowly
because it's rather important we've
learned a couple of things from the
legacy of the 20th century with okay
one is context matters etc etc etc the
one that is most serious this is my last
sentence of promise
the most serious from an analytical
point of view challenging from an
analytical point of view most
challenging and one that we're trying to
deal with is the third bullet and that
is to take into account account the time
factor
time is money we know that and time is
marches along somehow we know that too
but what else this time do now it's your
turn to answer the question thank you
I do Oh so apparently there is time for
questions yep hello I believe that we
are in an emergency situation as we
speak right now and I define emergency
as when you see the bullet coming at you
and you know there's not enough time to
get out of the way in particular I think
the emergency is one of oil I've seen
recent articles in the Wall Street
Journal where there was a clarion cry by
several accountants for large oil
companies I've spoken privately with
someone who was on the board of a major
oil company in the last five years there
was also a public statement made by the
CEO of total essay that there was no
possible way that we can meet their
progress the projected growth in the oil
requirements of the world and I believe
that we're looking at a permanent and
growing worldwide oil shortage in
approximately five to ten years and
we're at a time where changing out the
transportation fleet takes about 20
years so my questions to you are first
is this recognized in the energy staff
of MIT - what do you if given that this
is would be true what are the
implications for the economy and
political structure and stability of the
United States and three what are the
implications for world war in a
situation like this okay the first the
first answer the first question is yes
it's recognized and that's a very
important footnote here for those of us
that were members of the faculty in 1973
we're the first oil crisis the first big
one
the Institute's response was
establishment of the Energy Lab if you
recall
several of us were talking the other day
about the very unfortunate deja view
image we've gone through this before
we've seen I mean the words if we didn't
know that this was 2000 and something it
could have been 19 1973 with respect to
oil in a very narrow way that that
particular crisis disappeared as you
remember the decade of the 80s things
went smoother so I would say it's a
little worse than you have described it
because now not only do we have this oil
business and there hasn't been any good
news on the oil front for quite a while
I didn't show you the real scary part
which is the refinery the margins on the
refinery there the refineries are
operating almost at at full capacity and
that as they say ain't very good news
just pushing on the infrastructure in
addition to this we have all this other
stuff that's come along which is the co2
stuff which was not part of of the of
the 1973 oil crisis you know we didn't
recognize it at the time with respect to
to world war the core of what I do is
conflict and violence why do people go
to war and when is this going to happen
etcetera so I expect war anytime but I
don't I think I'd rather I do not want
to get into this
I also teach Middle East politics so you
can imagine how that's it yeah well the
Iraq's oil is not flowing the premise
first it's not clear to me that the
stabilization of the region is that the
u.s. presence is a major contributor to
stability in the region because the
instabilities don't come from
governments anymore
they come from groups people terrorists
good guy whatever the gut the the real
instability is happening because
governments are losing control over
their people so with or without the US
troops there and unless the u.s. is
going to try which is impossible my
colleagues tell me because of the
constraints the limits on manpower in
the military to really police the entire
region so the bottom line is it's not
clear to me whether the physical
presence is contributes to stability or
fuels instability hi can you hear me
yeah okay
I thought you said a couple of really
good things and I wanted to repeat thank
you and then I have I have served a
general concern but I won't really name
that I'm gonna ask a specific question
so one of the big factors in my life and
maybe it sounds like in yours is to help
people talk better about politics
because as you mentioned people find it
very uncomfortable and unless you're a
professional people almost don't want to
do it right so you're one of our few I'm
on the other side I'm not a professional
I never want to be but I want to talk
about it so I want to learn how to
talk about it so the other thing you
said that I really liked was that it was
on the slide about the world languages
and you said let me find the Quartus
there are some barriers to speaking
clearly and I think that sentence to me
encapsulate the entire problem of
talking about politics there are so many
barriers to clarity and in that vein
I'd like to ask for clarity on your
numerous pictures that showed the pretty
graphics of the world shapes and I
didn't know what the size of the country
meant as opposed to like for example it
seemed like there are borders they're
always there and no matter what
yeah and the colors also changed now I
wasn't sure what colors what because it
didn't clearly represent a rainbow to me
yeah first of all I apologize for not
being clear at the very beginning about
those maps this is a representation
these were distortions of the territory
based maps that were familiar with pick
up any atlas you see them the political
boundaries so it's just readjusting the
boundaries by the relative size of say
US population relative to the total
public population the colors were not
meant to be happy colors rainbows they
just were just those those colors and
about talking about politics I only do
it in class so I can't give you any
advice and the the the my last statement
is is this it's in the form of a PR for
for the research that we're doing but
it's rather interesting or important and
that is the global system for
sustainable development is an knowledge
networking system distributed system
that is me recited in China and
currently going to be me recited in in
Lebanon it it operates in four languages
that the two of which are not really
normal languages of everyday discourse
in the United States Arabic and Chinese
English of course and the fourth is it
is French and given the fact that the
world's population is not
english-speaking we're very pleased and
very very proud to be able to operate in
at least two of the major non-western
languages where we know there are lots
of people that don't speak English so if
you have a chance take a look at the the
GS SD website because this is a typical
MIT product and what is not difficult is
that it comes out of the social sciences
as opposed to the the rest of the campus
next I would well I'd like to say that
I'm thrilled and privileged to introduce
professor John Fernandez part of the
reason I'm thrilled is because as of
about 8:00 p.m. last night who was
trapped in the New Orleans Airport and
despite FAA computer crashes and
tropical weather systems he managed to
make his way here today so I really am
thrilled to be able to introduce
professor John Fernandez an associate
professor of building technology in the
MIT Department of Architecture and a
practicing architect professor Fernandez
primarily focuses his research on the
materials of buildings and the design of
assemblies for a resource efficient
built environment lately his interests
have been centered on the emerging
opportunities for linking design urban
planning and building technologies in
the creation of green cities and
resilient communities this morning
professor Fernandez will address the
growing challenge of limited global
resources amid an ever expanding urban
world please join me in welcoming
professor John Fernandez
can you hear me
mics on okay I have to do a little AV
shift here the AV person asked me to do
this I think I can do it although I'm
MIT faculty so might might might take a
little bit there we go okay yes I was in
New Orleans yesterday I flew in this
morning I really I did have a beautiful
black suit picked out it's it's at home
I do bike into work every day so I
rummaged through my office and I found
this
so please please bear with me um you
know I'm I'm thrilled to be here I am
part of the Department of Architecture
we're a little department at MIT just
across the street I'm class of 85 from
that department and back as faculty
thank you to IRA to the tech day
committee for inviting me I'm also I
just want to take a minute and thank the
class of 1957 not just because it is
your fiftieth but because that class was
very generous in supporting my work the
last few years as a career development
professor so I really very much
appreciate that clearly the topic of
resources and energy in particular is
the topic of the day it's going to be
the topic of generations to come that's
for certain
I'm trained as an architect so my
expertise is in buildings but in the
last few years
I've spent quite a lot of time on
linking resources and design and
engineering of buildings if you want to
pick one of Professor deutsches
strategies for dealing with the energy
issue my talk would probably fall under
moderate demand how to design better
buildings and how to design them in a
way that people reduce their demand
in last several years have actually
spent a quite a bit of time with a
variety of organizations including
architectural design firms various
companies now several cities and I'm
coming to the conclusion that the
momentum is there it's not political
momentum it is grassroots momentum for a
better built environment ok I like
organized presentations I'm compulsive
so I'm going to give you I'm the this is
organized around three questions okay
first it is really important to be very
clear about what the built environment
is what am I talking about
and I'll delve into that second is how
much of our global resources are
consumed by that environment not only in
operation but also in construction and
demolition and given what we know from
the fur from answers from the first two
questions should we even change should
we do we need to change will change in
the built environment make much of a
difference I'm gonna pose I'm gonna
throw out a lot of information lots of
pretty pictures I am an architect so but
I'm hoping that you can make your own
decision about whether the built
environment usually left out of the
discussion on energy I should say often
left out should be part of the core
discussion of energy energy and global
climate change issues so let's say let's
see what we can get out of this effort I
have 40 minutes I'm hitting a real brick
wall in terms of the schedule and that's
lunch at one o'clock so I'll make sure
to try to get you to your lunch on time
okay so what's the built environment
let's revert to some fundamentals the
built environment very directly stated
is that which provides shelter always
has provided shelter it's one of three
very basic fundamental needs of the
human species food and water being the
other two they're very very few places
on earth where you can live without
shelter
the critical role of shelters hasn't
changed but the diversity of shelters
buildings has changed as our activities
have evolved and become much much more
diverse so here this is actually a
photograph of the new building here in
Boston the Institute of Contemporary
Arts
when shelter was first invented there
was no such thing as Contemporary Art so
the diversity of activities has really
exploded and that's why the built
environment looks the way it does today
our first understanding of the world was
very much about where you could live and
where you couldn't what was habitable
and what was inhabitable
and creating shelter that allowed
migration and settlement was the
beginning of the making of the largest
longest lasting most material intensive
and now one of the most energy intensive
things we've ever made as a species and
that's what I want to call the built
environment over time this is actually
an image from a colleague of mine and
spurn in architecture over time very
slowly at first domestication
agriculture we all know this story along
with the building arts led to the
creation of settlements and this is not
abated ever since huge proportions of
our extracted material and energy
resources have been devoted to the
making of buildings settlements roads
dams all the infrastructure that we
depend on so that today this is what we
have this is the built environment this
could be this could be many different
cities concrete's the primary material
used to build the built environments
actually the second most consumed
material in the world second only to
water by people and actually concrete
also don't have this in my script here
but concrete contributes some somewhere
between six and eight percent of all co2
emissions so six to eight percent of
total co2 emissions the let me give you
some facts on where we are with the
built environment on a global scale
so within the last year this past year
or 18 months or two years it depends on
who you're talking to the global urban
population has surpassed 50 percent now
50 percent of the world lives in cities
and that will continue to increase
projections say pretty much forever but
you know that's pretty key in the future
I won't be here in 75 years so it's an
easy prediction to make a majority of
that urban populations with an easy
reach of the coast the fastest-growing
urban populations by far are located in
Asia and Africa and China now
astoundingly accounts for one half of
all construction in the world
as a result there are significant
resource issues to consider 80 percent
of co2 emissions is caused directly or
indirectly by people living in in cities
75% of wood consumption is used for
construction and fuel in cities and 60%
of water withdrawals also occurs to
serve the residents of cities this is a
world an urban world that is also a very
poor world and we should take note
although I won't go into that discussion
today that that's a really significant
issue because that level of affluence
will most likely increase and that's a
big factor that we will have to take in
terms of resource consumption and in the
future cities on the home front in the
US the built environment amounts to 130
million residential buildings we add
approximately 1.8 million residences
annually depending on the economy
six million commercial buildings 170
thousand new buildings of this type
annually and we demolish about 50,000
buildings a year commercial buildings a
year that again also varies
significantly with the economy the bad
news is that cities tend to promote more
intense resource consumption on a per
capita basis it's partly due because the
logistics of housing housing large
numbers of people getting them to work
having places for them to work in too
located around cities but also the
affluence that's gained from living in
cities and working in cities and
shopping in cities take for example the
increasing popularity of air
conditioners in cities around the world
now I want to pause here for a second
and say that I'm part of a group called
the building technology program and the
people standing behind me for now are
Marilyn Anderson John ochsendorf less
nor furred and Leon Glicksman we do all
of this work together and these air
conditioning numbers are something that
Leon and I Leon has talked about for
quite some time and I've taken them to
heart in China more than eighty seven
out of a hundred urban households now
own an air conditioner compared to
twenty four out of a hundred in two
thousand seven years ago as a result
China is now the world's largest
producer of air conditioners and India's
following closely behind now air
conditioning is something that a great
deal of the rest of the world is looking
forward to right this is happening now
and gaining momentum and will continue
to happen most furiously in expanding
cities the image I want to show I'm
showing here is actually a per capita
electricity consumption and just notice
the uptick sorry the uptick in a two
year period in Shanghai 1995 1997
massive urbanization liberalisation of
the housing market increasing number of
air conditioners and general affluence
increasing during that time it's a 76
percent increase and electrical
consumption in that city over a two-year
period Shanghai by the way for the past
several years and looks like next year
might be the same has added more
building space than exists annually than
exists in all of Manhattan that's every
year so let's do something here let's
generalize these ideas let's kind of
bring them together because there's a
really interesting I spend a lot of time
these past few years within dust
ecologist who refer to the work of
natural ecologists I'll leave it there
in terms of the the whole ecology debate
and is it a science or not but there is
a very useful concept that I've used in
my teaching before it's the concept of
succession and the idea that there's a
dynamic process by which one ecosystem
transforms into another over time and
seems to be done and seems to happen
often in sort of step function a rain
forest will transform into a savanna
will transform into a desert depending
on climactic changes and other factors
one result of succession is that the
profile of resource consumption for that
location
changes dramatically as it goes from one
kind of environment to another we can
actually apply this to cities especially
rapidly urbanizing urban centers around
the world and this is one of my own
graphs this comes from research on
Chinese cities a paper I wrote recently
published in the journal industrial
ecology on a massive urbanization of
China basically I think you can break it
down into three phases especially as I
said a massively urbanizing rapidly
urbanizing cities the first phase is
additions to stock and that is an
overwhelmingly material intensive phase
the second is a stabilization of that
stock so you're not building as much
it's becoming denser the limits may be
geographical limits of the city you're
you're hitting and it's done so fine so
it may be not adding as much you're
still adding quite a lot and then the
third phase is the incremental
densification the third phase is
actually a an energy intensive phase
because once you've added all this stock
the energy consumed by that stock stock
I mean buildings increases dramatically
and as those buildings live over time
and they're renovated and upgraded and
more amenities are inserted into them
the energy profile of these cities
changes so that the this curve the
material curve goes up and then goes
down so you know for example this is
Shanghai a few years ago this is maybe
Manhattan or Chicago and down here this
is Paris you don't see a lot of
demolition in the center of Paris
alright you don't see a lot of new
buildings so it's stabilized what is
important is to notice that there's a
change in the resource in the nature of
the resource consumption and so right
now all of these Asian cities that are
growing rapidly ours are in here we have
yet to see this part of the curve the
big energy uptick so that's that that is
what we're facing now consider the fact
as I stated before that 50% of the world
more than 3 billion people now lives in
cities and the world's population curve
is headed for something like 9 to 10
billion 20 40 50 if the global urban
population increases to a very
conservative 60 percent it will more
likely be somewhere in the 70s at least
five and a half billion people will
eventually be living in these future
cities that's two and a half billion
more people in the cities than today
consuming materials and energy at urban
rates not at the rural rate that many of
them are now or would have been without
massive urbanization so this is what I
mean by the built environment snapshot
of today a little bit of the future
let's go to question two
how much of our global resources is
consumed I've touched a little bit on a
few consumption issues but let me be a
little bit more specific let's start
with the US the and let's set that we
with the u.s. construction industry
construction industry is this vast messy
thing of two hundred and twenty thousand
separate businesses makes it
construction industry is composed of
that many but separate businesses most
of them one two three person firms that
represents more than six hundred billion
dollars in annual revenue and employs
roughly two million people
notably this industry fragmented as it
is into hundreds of thousands of
companies has historically lagged very
far behind other large industries in its
investment for research and development
and you asked your question you asked
the question why our buildings built the
same way today as they were 50 75 years
ago well the industry spends about one
tenth of research and development as any
other comparably sized or any other
large industry really even mid-sized
industry let's go to the energy
consumption of that building stock in
the u.s. now the built stock is produced
by this industry is really one of the
again I mentioned that not always
mentioned consumer of primary energy it
does account for 40 percent of primary
Energy's residential and commercial
office buildings also 60 to 70 percent
and now I use that range because now I'm
talking about developed countries it's
fairly consistent throughout of
electricity consumption 60 or 70 percent
the figure the 40 percent increases to
48 percent if one includes the energy
using in manufacturer building materials
and construction operating buildings
contributes over 38 percent now closely
correlated to the electrical consumption
38 percent of carbon emissions of the
United States 38 percent these numbers
are consistent across the developed
world with some with some notable
exceptions now in the developing world
energy consumption devoted to the built
environment is a difficult number to get
at hard to get good data and though
there a number of studies to be done but
we can note a couple of facts that
outline the future of energy consumption
in the next couple of decades in using
the OECD country designations in 2015
non-oecd countries will surpass the OECD
group in their overall energy
consumption 2015 eight years between now
and 2030 non-oecd countries will account
for three-quarters of the increase in
energy consumption again that's Asia
Africa
others and by that year their energy
consumption will exceed that of the OECD
by 34% let's take one component only one
I don't have time to go through heating
and cooling and all the other could but
let's just take one again one that's not
often mentioned and that is the energy
and lighting 19 percent of global
electricity uses devoted to lighting
alone almost 20 percent I'd love to show
this image with this sort of sobering
fact before I believe me it gets more
positive a little later I love to show
this little the this image below I mean
above that fact because this is a design
of Santiago Calatrava
in Milwaukee Milwaukee Art Museum and
it's a holy day lit space as part of the
main hall it's a photograph of a MIT
undergraduate David Fox who's graduated
a couple years ago okay
let's also talk about construction
materials okay
this huge material flow is associated
with the built environment in fact a
study showed that 70 percent by weight
of all material flows through most
developed industrialized countries is
devoted to construction twenty to thirty
percent of the entire societal waste
stream stems from construction and
demolition waste or nearly 60% of total
non industrial waste of this
construction in the of this construction
and demolition waste stream forty eight
percent is the result of demolition 44
percent result of renovation with the
remainder being new construction today
in the states were recovering
approximately twenty to thirty percent
depending of the year of construction
and demolition waste and this just shows
I know you can't see the thing all the
million tons this is year this is
construction I can't even read it myself
industrial and is that agriculture is at
the bottom oh yeah okay from what I
remember okay I mean you can also look
at a per capita material consumption in
the United States and you know these are
kind of amusing a graphic here 3.6
million pounds of minerals metals and
fuels
are consumed by every American and their
lifetime a huge bulk of that is
construction the movement on all that
material costs a lot of energy let's
talk just a little bit more about
materials because materials is kind of
my thing also spent a good few years
studying the materials of construction
this is looking at the material flows
where construction has and material
flows in society generally has led to
some landmark studies recently colleague
of mine well at Yale
Tom Tom Gradle he's in the school
forestry in the environment has done a
whole series of studies on the material
flow of the existing stocks of primary
metals and he has shown rather
conclusively that a third of that is
left in the ground in very low grade
ores a third is in circulation in
buildings like this and automobiles
industrial equipment and a third has
been lost forever in that process
dissipated to the environment why is
this why is this important or useful to
know well we're slowly approaching not
limits to growth but actually the
realization that some of the best
locations some of the richest locations
for some some of the more important
materials we have are not in this kind
of place this is copper mine it's just
the mine tailings that you see from the
air and aerial photo but actually copper
concentrations are now starting to be
richest in cities this is actually this
is a graph of actually Beijing and each
one of these bars is not a proposed
super skyscraper but the concentration
of copper and in that city let's
remember a a very prescient poignant in
fact quote of Jane Jacobs our cities are
the mines of the future
let me tell you my own personal
experience not only in New Orleans but
in New Orleans specifically but in other
cities there's a funny thing that's
happened recently there's a recent
emergence of what's called midnight
plumbers
and these are in primarily they're
starting to show up in inner-city
housing complexes mostly from Baltimore
to New Orleans and what they are as you
can imagine is they are people who are
stripping the plumbing from unoccupied
or lightly occupied or temporarily
vacant apartments and I read an article
recently in the New York Times which was
had this interesting fact the landlord
had said that he had noticed this was
happening and there had a specific
number he said you know when when 20
pounds of copper equals or exceeds the
minimum wage for one day you start
seeing this stuff China okay so that's
there's there is it's very you know the
we're I don't want to talk about limits
of growth although you can ask me
questions about it but but I do want to
talk about the shifting of the location
and the the accessibility to important
materials for society but also for the
built environment and generally okay now
this brings up an issue about the way we
treat our buildings because it is very
clear that until very recently the only
measure of value for our buildings has
been a financial measure it's a real
estate instrument it is on a ledger as a
as an abstract thing it is not
necessarily considered a physical thing
it's I wish you could hear all the
cheers of the crowd here coming out of
my laptop but it these buildings have
been treated as you know essentially
things that can be moved around a
chessboard well I think we're hitting
the time when the up-and-coming
professionals designers architects
engineers are starting to see that
that's not such an easy game to play any
longer especially with our
infrastructure this by the way was the
the demolition of the Seattle Kingdom
and it was an amazing building is
actually the longest thin shell concrete
span in the world it's its cousin the
Pantheon lasted has lasted for a long
time the Seattle Kingdom
lasted 25 years when it was it was only
25 years when it's demolished just just
thought of college so now there's a lot
of interest in and when you read about
green buildings one of the first things
you'll read about is green materials
recycled materials low energy materials
well let's be real actually in terms of
society societal consumption of
materials it's pretty clear we're not
being any more renewable than we used to
be so say 1950 proportions so this is
this is renewable versus non-renewable
versus renewable materials of
proportions of which on societal
consumption so this includes other
things besides the built environment but
as we know seventy percent by weight
material flow so so the built
environment plays a large role here
that's my disclaimer the in 1950 we were
there today we're not doing any better
we're doing worse 95 percent
non-renewable to 5 percent so this is a
trend that we really do have to think
about especially when we factor in the
energy that it takes to push all these
materials around ok I want to round out
question 2 how am i doing on time
yeah 33 minutes with a measure a
composite measure that I think you I'm
sure you are all very first of you're
better informed about this than I am but
the ecological footprint a measure a
composite measure developed the latest
version developed by recent Bhakra
Nangal they keep a website a global
footprint Network org the global the the
ecological footprint is a measure of the
global societal demand versus supply of
biologically productive land for
everything that we do from agriculture
to construction to manufacture of
building materials a couple of recent or
relatively recent thresholds one
particularly ominous one that we crossed
and you can certainly debate the way
they calculate
the ecological bio capacity of the earth
but in nineteen in the late 1980s we
crossed this is number of planet Earth's
right so one planet Earth the bio
capacity of one planet Earth is at line
right there this is years six sixty
seventy eighty ninety so in late 80s if
you and this is a huge physical
accounting exercise that the group goes
through and they've been doing France
peer-reviewed and massive effort in the
late 80s they determined that we cross
the threshold in going from on an annual
basis demanding more than the supply
could give us okay that doesn't mean
that you can't supply all of that demand
in the future it just means that well
we're digging into the natural capital
basically and you dig into it you dig
into natural capital far enough and you
can endanger Serkan certain Ecology's
like a an old-growth forest you log it
enough and it's no longer a diverse bio
diverse environment it's something else
in 1960 the population of the world was
three billion two thousand six point one
actually interesting thing is while you
double it and you get more this the the
ecological footprint was 0.5 Earth's
that's one point two and the difference
between those two if one would expect
that maybe 0.5 at six billion would be
one well the difference between them is
include the increase in affluence and
our increasing ability to extract the
resources that we want so that right now
we're at one point two earths and
scheduled to continue rising this feeds
into the discussions about tipping
points on various Ecology's around the
world okay so that's the built
environment the way I kind of the
filtered way that I see it for today in
45 minutes
the third question let's address that
should we change the future well I'm
already convinced because I'm one of
four points on a slide and professor in
Joyce's presentation that yeah we
shouldn't okay because we're talking
about moderating demand essentially and
designing better so that demand doesn't
increase there's a there's there's a lot
I could say about using the ecological
footprint to answer this question let me
suggest a direct answer for now today
and tomorrow and into the future
this is something that you can do look
at the buildings around you including
this one the buildings that you live and
work in the buildings that you visit for
most of those buildings in the United
States you can decrease its energy
consumption by 10 to 15 percent with a
buyback time of about five years no
question about it you can do it tomorrow
those are efficiency savings better
insulation and better windows the way
fuel prices are going heating fuel
prices and an electricity it is possible
to do that within a five year payback
this can best be done I'm also not going
to talk about solar because this can
best be done with an integrated approach
accessing renewable energy sources solar
micro wind turbines and and other
technologies but it it should be coupled
with efficiency conserving energy be
more efficient in our use of the energy
that's already provided to us for our
buildings let me give you another answer
to this question which I think should be
a kind of a rule of thumb for green
building people in around the world and
that is it's probably best to increase
the energy efficiency in existing
buildings in the developed world because
we have a lot of stock and we have a lot
of very underperforming stock still
build a lot but we certainly don't build
this and much or we'll build as much as
the developing world
and that leads to the second point which
is it's very important to the to
increase the efficiencies in the way new
buildings are brought on online in
developing countries a couple of those
two together and you've got a very
powerful strategy for moderating demand
globally for the built environment you
know what I'm I also I spent a lot of
time with students I teach a lot I I
just got tenured thanks to the class of
57 and I want to say you guys really
helped out so actually what I want to
bring in here are students I want to
answer the question from the student
point of view because I see the student
body as being an extraordinarily
powerful force in all of this I want to
answer the question through Tom weathers
Tom if you're watching hello tom is a
recently graduated just yesterday master
of architecture students MIT and he
dedicated his thesis the full three
semesters of pre thesis researched and
then and actually writing it too
investigating the possibilities for
using the existing material flow here on
campus the MIT campus particularly
underutilized but valuable waste tree
materials in the design and construction
of a low-energy building his question
was do we
is there enough flow around us that we
can maybe capture some of it and make a
good building he produced as a result of
this study as far as I know the first
comprehensive material flow analysis of
the MIT community and then he analyzed
it for the potential for use in new
buildings while this study so the idea
is so waste that's floating out there
capture it and make a new building
sounds very academic in some ways kind
of unseemly I guess but but in Lexington
just north of here there is a house that
was built of the detritus previously the
detritus Demery most of the primary
structural elements many of the very law
very very high embodied energy materials
in this building a lot of the exterior
envelope materials were directly
captured from that flow and you can look
at the big dick and say well that was a
huge material flow
well some of that was captured a tiny
tiny little less than a drop was
captured for this building but it's a
really interesting approach to the way a
designer would think about what are the
resources that I have that my disposal
another student I want to mention here
is this Lucille innocencio Lucille is a
current Master of Architecture student
they both gave me permission to show
these you know they're happy with it and
she's also very much a person who thinks
that we should change the future her
project of last term in this in design
studio brought into focus the need to
consider architectural form as shaped by
the potential offered by solar radiation
by the Sun like an old topic but so much
of our architectural form has nothing to
do with the Sun so much of our
architectural form is oriented to what
the street alright
fly anywhere look at the little curving
streets and where how are the houses
located they all follow the street so
that the idea is that there needs to be
designed technology and planning that
directly proposes that the configuration
of buildings should follow the potential
for solar heat gain so shading not a new
idea in fact let's remember that this
approach really had its origins one of
its origins here in the solar houses at
MIT in the 1930s way back in the 1930s
in fact in 1938 the Committee on solar
energy utilization at MIT was set up and
for the next 50 years until 1988 six a
series of six experimental and
prototypical houses were built here at
MIT and served very much as the seeds to
things like this this is the Passivhaus
Institute this is material from the
pacifist Institute in Germany a person
there named Wolfgang Feist
paid attention to the MIT work and he
spent a lot of time perfecting a
combination of super insulated shell
with heat recovery the breath that I
breathe the heat that I'm producing can
be recovered and then preheat incoming
air from
outside high-performance windows and a
systematic elimination elimination of
thermal bridges between the inside of
the outside the cold outside in the warm
inside for example and he produced a
design the passive house
and it's a really important approach to
residential architecture for the United
States 68% of our US housing stock is
still single-family housing and the
median age of our US housing stock is 27
years which means that were a country of
new housing and this kind of approach
still has relevance we can still
applauding 10,000 of these houses have
been built this is not a pipe dream this
is not the he action Wolfgang Feist one
office okay so these MIT people have
done all of this now I want to make it
real I want to make it happen in the
world and he did 10,000 have been built
in Germany the Passivhaus Institute has
expanded its range to include other
building types multi-family multi-unit
residential buildings apartment houses
schools office buildings community
centers the passive house let's be let
me be very direct clear they've been a
whole series of conferences on the
passive house lots and lots of data
taken over 10 years I think there have
been seven passive house conferences I
know that's probably wrong but it's
close this is typical alright and again
here let me just give you so the
kilowatt hour per meter squared here a
passive house well but build passive
house but but perfectly well verified
and standard passive house construction
will lead to an 85 to 90 percent
reduction and energy this is in Germany
this is a and and other parts of and and
northern Europe there's a group that I'm
actually talking to quite a lot who's
got a demonstration project in Uxbridge
they're they're bringing they've
actually licensed the passive house
technology they're bringing it to
expertise you're going to build a
building there MIT hopefully we'll be
monitoring it so that was so that that
the passive house can become
commercialized in in the in this country
so in my opinion and in light of the
first kind of sobering two-thirds of
this presentation I think all of this
last few slides is very good news
because the built environment does offer
an opportunity to improve our resource
efficiency while revisiting again the
value that we place on architectural
spaces in the public realm this is
actually one of my buildings I had to
throw it out there it is actually before
I had any of these thoughts in my mind
that's before I came to MIT this is
actually in addition to the law school
at Columbia University they needed
public space and it's south oriented and
these aluminum fins and that fretted
glass which is a kind of veiled cloud
and I'm all baked down to the UM to the
gloss is is basically designed for solar
heating in the winter and none in the
summer very very straightforward idea
another project another kind of project
which really my project the should
before really did come out of the work
of the MIT solar house is an idea of
solar architecture other projects have
come out of that other technologies
including aerogels super insulating
silica foamed materials having upwards
of 10 to 20 times the thermal resistance
of typical insulating materials and
another building okay so this is this is
solar house taken to an extreme
commercial office building we see of
them we see them all over the place
glass buildings this building shades
itself its shields itself it's very
straightforward very simple idea we
don't see a lot of this around so that's
why I'm an optimist I think they're very
straightforward simple actually quite
beautiful solutions to moderating demand
we do need material research fundamental
during the material research and I've
done some assemblies research
depending on the material scientists we
do need inexpensive and high performance
thermal insulation materials we still do
inexpensive responsive spectrally
selective coatings for glass desiccant
materials of all kinds to
rate humidity when you bring in outside
air self-healing vapor and air barriers
I think we're on the cusp of a number of
breakthroughs there and and more we need
more fundamental research on the
materials for buildings and we're seeing
some of this we're seeing the more
inventive maybe not as risk-averse or
maybe very successful architects so they
can take some risks doing these things
on a big scale this is actually these
are shots from Renzo pianos New York
Times building in Times Square if you
haven't seen it during New York City go
visit it's a building with a huge solar
shade on it it's an amazing building
these are ceramic tubes around the
entire thing it's got a veil to temper
that solar heat King still entirely
glass building and this is the Hearst
building 57th Street and 8th I think and
that again has very sophisticated
spectrally selective glass as part of
its wall system also they're very very
exotic materials that we really do need
to spend some effort on and these are
things like phase change materials so
high thermal mass mature materials that
soak or give off absorb or give off heat
as they change state these are extremely
useful materials all of your seats could
have phase change materials in them and
we could lower the temperature of this
room all right so because the the
thermal exchange would be after the user
sorry at the user where it matters not
not up there in that volume where it
doesn't matter as much solid-state
lighting is a huge field important field
to reduce that artificial lighting
because there is a paper that is
published in March 30 2007 so it's
fairly recent it's on the materials for
aesthetic energy efficient and
self-diagnostic buildings so but in
addition to materials we also need some
decision-making tools for the designer
this is a material selector software the
mechanical engineers have had material
selection software for a few decades now
the aero-astro certainly have
and the architects and the engineers the
stewards of 70% of that material
throughput have not so we with my cash
be at the University of Cambridge in the
UK you know I developed this as a tool
an initial tool to to give architects an
idea of how to make rational decisions
between materials that they're
considering this is just actually
showing you that production energy are
embodied energy which you can't read
versus co2 emission very tightly
correlated so body of energy of it to
your own that co2 that's emitted that's
a that's a tightly correlated pairing of
properties and I haven't talked about
the production of power in buildings so
I'm building integrated renewable
energies photovoltaics I'm not even
showing photovoltaics photovoltaics is a
whole nother topic and I think it is
extraordinarily important and will be
part of the solution for moderating
demand but I also wanted to show you
some you know not maybe not so commonly
seen images of a building actually these
are renderings of a building in Chicago
recently built I think completed by the
previously big corporate architect
Helmut yan and that's a micro turbine
turbine on the top of it runs the length
of the building and purportedly is
supposed to be delivering the lighting
energy for for low income housing by the
way okay so the huge elephant in the
room is global climate change which I
haven't really spoken about I'll just
spend just a couple of slides it's 51 I
have like three minutes right so there
are there's a topic that I'd like to
introduce not get into today but tell
you that it is the umbrella topic for
the free efficiency as you see an image
of Hurricane Rita heading for New
Orleans this talk of efficiency gains
was really set under the uncertainty of
vast changes to ecological anthropogenic
systems due to global climate change if
energy efficiency is brought to the
built environment do not account for the
uncertainty of global climate change
will you run the risk of being
overwhelmed by producing buildings that
rapidly become inappropriate in their
locations and for their occupants an
emerging sediment priorities then is
starting to really change the way a
growing group of designers IRA mentioned
this designers dust real ecologist
engineers planners urban planners are
thinking about the new future city the
green city that is if we can accept the
notion that the built environment is one
very large complex system then it would
be prudent to explore the ways in which
that system can be designed with an
enhanced capacity for adaptation and
resilience an ability to respond to
shocks to the system so I'll leave you
just with two current designs designs
that I'm working on one is a kind of a
modest proposal it's for a house we're
calling it the MIT float house I am
privileged to be involved in a number of
projects in New Orleans believe me in
the next two years are gonna be really
interesting in New Orleans a lot a lot
is happening not only just because of
the hurricanes but a lot of you go to
any restaurant there and no one in the
the room no one in the restaurant had
been there pre Katrina and they're all
PhDs and engineers and all I mean it's
an interesting place this house has
designed it proposes an alternative to
relying on a centralized levee based
flood protection system very simple the
house floats when the city floods
the city will flood people are building
now houses slab on grade in other words
the concrete on a grade building up and
well flood so okay so but the
implication here is is goes far beyond
just this design and that is is there an
opportunity to rethink the way we
actually deploy infrastructure and we
actually design architecture not to
depend on these large centralized
systems for even for power generation
for example what if we were to develop
ways in which just we could distribute
using micro grids of renewable energy
community organized and owned systems
for power generation that would
simultaneously lead to a reduction in
demand because and anyone that owns the
the thing that's producing energy is
going to maintain it they can want to
know how much energy is being there they
have the knowledge of what it is that
they're getting I you just you just
write a check to the energy company for
that power plant which is 70 miles away
well there's kind of a different
engagement dynamic going on there okay
so but it also then says that that
community could be more resilient to
shocks so when it does flood this house
elevates because it's got a chassis of
buoyant material it's held in place
because you've got pantographs which
allow for that for well that that make
for a purely vertical rise and keep it
in place
so it deals with lateral movement and it
and these hydraulic columns fill with
water
so these fill with water the flood goes
away water goes away this is not a
fiction the floodwaters are going the
house is still up because the thing you
also want to do is to protect the house
from looting so it's a lot harder to
hard it dilute this house and okay so
the owner comes back or the community
comes back and slowly lowers each one
okay the the second proposal I actually
want to talk about I'm a designer I
throw out these ideas we see what sticks
right the other idea I'm really and this
is um
both of these are real projects I'm
talking to a developer on
the house I showed you before and this
project is also in play and that is the
idea which I just mentioned the zero
energy community that uses that has an
emergency water cistern on-site storm
retention basins thermal storage
reservoir or phase change materials that
can circulate throughout all the
buildings micro wind turbines building
integrated photovoltaics an emergency
power source served by the micro grid
and a local flood surge break all within
the goal of a diminished carbon
footprint this is the idea of a
resilient semi autonomous community that
is now green so these are some some
ideas that I'm working on recently I
think this is the direction that at
least for me in my work in building
technology this is where I think we can
contribute to moderating demand let me
just read my last paragraph here the
idea of that resilience and adaptability
can be designed priorities initiates a
whole new era for architecture that
incorporates as central core priorities
are evolving understanding of global
resource consumption and climate change
it will certainly be a challenge to
fully assume this approach within a
business that has always resisted any
change but I'm quite optimistic that
real change productive and positive is
coming I think you can be a critical
part of that too there's an enormous
wealth of momentum here I'm not entirely
counting on political momentum political
will counting on a lot of other kinds of
will so if you hire an architect as
opposed to what bookie Fuller asked the
architect how much does your well
building away using years ago though the
decent question to ask by the way you
should ask your architect how is the
person or firm going to produce a
strategy for reducing the resource
consumption of that architectural
proposal
I hope personally that the answer that
you get comes from one of my former
students because then I can rest assured
that it will be both effective and
beautiful thank you
so I can take five minutes worth of
questions yes first first I'd like to
say that I was really disappointed up
until your talk because they thought I
was at the other place down the river
because it was all blabber and very
little reality and you brought a lot of
reality to this thing no I mean
seriously because you can do all kinds
of studies and projections and
everything but you're building real
things and and you're dealing with real
real things and and that's very
important because if we knew the answers
we'd be at Foxwoods not here can I
respond actually - able to the quiz yeah
but I did say that my piece was one part
of one of four was moderating demand my
opinion is moderating demand will be an
extraordinarily small portion of what
will contribute to the stabilization of
co2 levels in the atmosphere and all
that so it's good so it's one really
small part all the other abstract work
in large infrastructure systems all that
I am totally on board with all of that
having to be talked about in the way
that Professor Deutsch talked about of
which is that if I say it's possible
somebody doesn't say oh I can do it
tomorrow but we need to figure out how
to do well well first of all as a as the
head of NASA said you know why are we
saying that this is the climate that we
necessarily want to maintain why don't
we just see perhaps that we can adapt to
the climate as we have always adapted to
the climate when it got cold
we put clothing on built shelter when it
got warm you know we moved or whatever
the case may be so the point is and the
second thing is you know it's really
really bad for people in a place like
MIT to deny reality in the sense that
they say co2 is the most important
greenhouse gas I'm sorry
and yes any gas with those number of
atoms that present will do essentially
the same thing in water vapor which is
far more prevalent in the atmosphere is
much more important as a greenhouse gas
but let's leave that out there
question is this if you foresee the
global drive going the way it is and
that's again a projection with
decreasing population growth rates in
the developed countries how do we take
advantage of our expertise and our
knowledge in the built environment and
transfer that in a productive way to the
third world fourth world whatever where
the big growth is going to occur how do
we do it okay we're docq
so there's a very very quick answer
because I go I want to get one other
question in here the answered question
is that is happening there are literally
hundreds of people thinking exactly
about that question and doing different
things for example one quick example is
lead in the United States so you know
lead is a leadership and energy and
environment environmental design it's a
building rating system I think that's
correct
building rating system that is intended
to be used by architects to certify that
they've done as much as they can to
reduce a resource consumption of their
buildings it's a rating system it's not
an actual monitoring of that but it is a
it is a tool that's now being
transferred to countries all over the
attempt is to transfer it to countries
all over the world so that at least
there's a benchmark that architects can
work with so that's that's just very
very quick but but rest assured there's
a hue there's this very good awareness
and there's huge effort to transfer what
we know to the developing world and by
the way the developing world is more
politically progressive than many of the
countries in the developed in the
developed world I think might be any
percentage of reduction of energy
consumption from simply planning
deciduous trees like on the southwest
sides of the home yeah great question so
so and that is to hit solar heat gain so
when you reduce solar heat King you can
be in and it varies tremendously with
climate but in a climate like this solar
heat gain on the west side for example
late afternoon the building's already
warm they're there I'm not going to give
you a number but there is significant
savings that you can have by making sure
that that building does not he
late in the afternoon and you and you
continue to need some kind of air
conditioning and but it's it's a good
point okay actually I'm being really um
this the point is being stressed that
lunches on the tables enjoy thank you
you
you